one of the things that's most
interesting to me as an aviation geek as
an aviation nerd is if you were to say
to an average individual or maybe a
commercial pilot a lot of commercial
pilots listen to this and they were to
see something what is your first step
what do people do and and it could be
even on the ground witnessing some sort
of phenomena but in particular in the
air just take it from that perspective
I'm flying along the coast of California
I see something what do I do well you do
what you should always do as a pilot
which is aviate navigate and communicate
you shouldn't necessarily let yourself
be distracted by what you're seeing at
this point in the game right you don't
know what this object is the idea here
is if you see something that's
unidentified that you should now you
know go deviate from your course to go
inspector something like that right so
that's not what's being communicated
here you should be a professional pilot
if you do observe it and you believe it
could be a threat uh to other air
traffic the proper procedure would be to
reach out to your air traffic controller
and see if um that traffic is known and
if not you'd like to give them a
position where it is so they can uh warn
other traffic about it uh one thing I've
been hearing from talking with
commercial pilots is that essentially
what's been happening right now is that
they'll see something either at their
altitude or in the vicinity of their
altitude other aircraft are seeing it as
well and they're calling up the ATC and
they're all kind of confirming it that
it's there that they don't know what it
is and they can visually see it but
there's nothing else really to do at
that point so that's part of the problem
I've been trying to U resolve is that
there is no real mechanism to report
this uh both from a a military
perspective as well as a commercial
perspective on the military perspective
disappointing to see we didn't really
have the ability to report unknown
objects in any way that would have got
resolved it was simply we had the Navy
Aviation safety reporting mechanisms uh
and those are you know not an
investigatory type uh of system it's typ
reports yeah so you know it's data
collection after the fact so there
really was nothing and if those
represented you know potentially
adversarial platforms that was
ultimately my fear at the time was that
these could have potentially been some
type of platform to spying on us and
that's something I've been communicating
a bit on I'm getting off track here so
I'll jump back on the commercial side
what what should the pilots do right now
in the far in the far the uh Federal
Aviation regulations I believe it is it
instructs air crew if they would like to
report uh one of these they don't
require it in any way they essentially
suggest that the the air crew or the
witness could go report that to any
number of quote UFO Reporting centers
that are out in the general public none
of which are well funded or you know
consistent with each other and so more
or less information just gets scattered
out and so that's one of the issues that
I'm working to resolve from a procedural
point with the aiaa to be able to make
those recommendations also with the
other organization I started Americans
for safe Aerospace where we can provide
general education and education on
Capitol Hill to be able to push for
those procedures be able to push for
that you know potentially mandatory
reporting so that Pilots don't feel like
they can't can't bring that information
forward to
ATC is it I mean there's a stigma on
Aviation you know you do something
there's a pilot deviation the air
traffic controllers here's a phone
number to call you know which you're
supposed to write down right after you
had some incident you know is there a
sense that like Pilots are not reporting
because they're going to get on some
list with you know Will Will Smith's
going to come up and do some clicking to
them or or that the FAA is going to pull
their ticket they can't fly anymore on
the commercial side is there concerns
about that I don't think it's uh
anything uh you know menum black
nefarious but guys just generally don't
want to be associated with it they don't
want to answer for it uh they'd rather
keep their head down and you know I say
that from the context of the people that
have been calling me for the past you
know eight months or more that's what
they're reporting and when they reached
out to me you know some of the stories
where guys didn't even want to call it
out to ATC because they didn't want
their call sign associated with that
report essentially so that's where the
State of Affairs was of course it's not
evenly spread but I hear that's better
now people are calling it out more but
it was disappointing to see that during
the NASA independent study team public
meeting that the fa representative
communicated that he wasn't even aware
of any procedures for Pilots to report
on this things right yeah they seem to
be good at you know kind of punishing
pilots and and if the FAA is out there
please do not you know pull my ticket
Ariel we we talked over lunch not too
long ago about you know events things
you saw when you were in combat or in
training you're flying a super horn at
also by were you both single seat Pilots
was it both single seat aircraft or do
you guys double I was single seat uh
Ryan flew two seaters you told me once
and maybe you could tell the story but
your encounter with a UAP at the
time can you actually actually no no I
in both cases it was it observable for
me so I I didn't have any anything uh to
crazy I one time in the whiskey areas
off the coast of Virginia we did pick up
a lot of little like scatter and uh one
I was able to to lock onto this and it
ended up I did a right to right with a
balloon there was another time in the
Persian Gulf and this was more worrisome
because I'm coming off the carrier I
pick up a a contact going real slow uh
not getting called out from from uh air
traffic on at the boat lock him up uh I
have a 9x missile which Al has another
sensor on it and that actually get tone
which tells me there's something there
uh end up doing a right to right with a
Iranian drone right to right means
you're you're squaring off basically we
just kind of flew right by yeah so it
was an Iranian drone that was orbiting
near the near the carrier you know
dangerous from a standpoint of one we
should be aware that it's there which
the boat may have been it was just more
warning the pilots hey you know and you
know I remember reading in Donald rell's
biography you of all places that you
know he said once that if uh President
Bush wanted to kill somebody it took
about 17 different phone calls and you
know telegrams and encrypted you know
data sources before that person would
meet his uh untimely his or her we
should be
inclusive a lot of a lot of you know wor
some women out there right um what what
about that if you saw this you identify
it as as some threat from a from a
hostile Nation do you have authorization
you have tone you know I mean you said
that that means by the way we should we
should although you and I are Aviation R
is as well what is lock on what kind of
sensor technology are we talking about
these are radar sensors a flare what
what are they exactly the radar usually
is the first sensor you're going to use
uh that's kind of your broadest that's
going to pick up the most everything
else starts to to zero in so in that
case I was coming off the boat and we
have to do checks on our our system so
that's why I I use the 9x and that's
that's a Sidewinder missile it's a heat
heat it looks for heat sources you know
even at that point my my craft safe
there's no way for me to shoot this
missile like man I have no intention to
do that to broader on your question we
would have to have I mean There Are
Rules of Engagement that are very clear
that dictate how you can employ your
weapon systems and with it being a
peacetime scenario unless that drone
fired upon me or was looking to be a
threat to US forces there's nothing I
would really legally be able to do we're
hamstrung pretty tightly with the Roe
but it also allows you to keep keep
yourself safe um but you know
fortunately we're not in in in
hostilities at that or fortunately we're
not in hostilities so right well yeah